[Music]
you
we have all heard of love stories
starting on social media or like the
internet and stuff and there's this one
that recently has gone viral
from tick tock so oh my god is it me and
my girlfriend
oh
that's a country dude hey we had an
article written on us i'll submit it
today
wow tell me i was asking during lunch
time i'm like hey i need one no i'm not
gonna be like hey can we talk about us
please no we got viral on tick tock as
well but please go on with with the
other couple
oh that's not so good the non-talented
couple
the unsinkable [ __ ] i'm single
um okay so we're talking about josiah
and natalie here
i love them so much and their love story
is so
cute i'm going to show you guys the tick
tock
that where they talk about their love
story i don't know who they are
[Music]
i know we need that
so this is what they look like they look
happy
they do look happy here we go
okay that's good okay what's gonna
happen now it's not a car crash is it
here we go
so i know this is gonna sound crazy but
i just flew across the country to meet a
girl that i met on tick tock to help her
drive back to her home in miami
this one of my videos came up on her for
you page on my instagram i saw her
picture and i was like she's cute so i
stalked her page pretty hard and then
slid into her dm's we started texting a
lot and i finally asked her on a
facetime date which i got pretty dressed
up for
and then we talked a lot we talked for a
few hours every day for the next few
weeks and i was falling pretty hard
i secretly messaged her sister to see if
i could send her a few of her favorite
snacks including an old hoodie i wore on
a first date
she loved it kept talking and then she
was going to come back to my amy to stay
with her family
and i had the idea what if we go on a
road trip what better way to get to know
somebody to drive across the country
with them she thought about it and said
okay
i made sure to call her parents and let
them know i'd take care of their
daughter got a haircut
packed my bags set my alarm got in the
car thanks again mom
and drove super early to the airport
here i am going to meet a girl i met on
tick tock in the middle of a pandemic
there's a lot of thoughts going on
inside my head
maybe it won't work out but maybe it
will either way we'll have a great story
to tell
stay tuned it's so cute yeah it's so
cute part two and three
yeah there's a lot of other parts too
and they they're just like documenting
their relationship now at this point
because
during that road trip like he said uh he
flew to l.a
drove all the way to florida they went
to the grand canyon and that's when he
asked her to be his girlfriend wow
they had their official first kiss wow
but
yes crazy like having your first date be
a across the country road trip do people
do like old school
like can you be my girlfriend else or
not do you like me old school like
traditions like
where you talk to people's parents you
know they let them know recording yeah
do people still do that did you do that
with me
yeah like he did i don't know if that
like i i head up your mom separately
they
have
that stuff i don't know if people still
do that or becoming a couple
um well like i guess like to let yeah i
guess like after to let them know you're
we were gonna be serious
the first thing i did was i was like hey
i want to have dinner with your mom
that's what you got claim jumpers really
it's awesome
i like the old school i like i like i
like establishing formal relationships
like letting people know like this is
what's going to happen
we're going to be doggy styling after so
i need your help you guys need a doggy
style before and then go
no perfecto we
you guys did a great job with your
daughter she's got a tight [ __ ]
thank you for that
i can't can i like you're like at clean
jumpers and you're just eating the
[ __ ] mac and cheese and you're like
[ __ ] is off the chain [ __ ] baby
wow macaroni in the pot well i wanted to
so i wanted to see what her parents were
like and i also wanted
her parents to also approve of who i am
too so that was important and then also
we did the same with my parents
especially if they're tight with their
parents yeah i feel like that is
important
my mom always said you don't marry the
person you're with you marry their
family so
yeah so she said watch out slash the
kids
yeah she's like you marry their family
so if you don't like their family she's
like
it's not just her or your girlfriend why
is woman
just keep bringing a girlfriend yeah
she's like because then if it's just
youtube you keep it between
you two and she's like there's we don't
have to get along with them and she goes
but
you have to think like are these the
type of people you want
connected with your family like some
people they have
drunks and scam artists and all these
people and i was like do you want to
bring them with our drunks and
and i was like oh yeah you got to think
about thanksgiving dinner
too many too many
so back to with this video what i found
uh surprising and funny is that this is
on tick tock
and even though it's on tick tock
they're still using royalty-free music
for his background music like what
what's the point tick-tock doesn't even
care
no they probably use the future they use
the rising sounds you know this you're a
tick-tock
no this this song no i feel like a
youtube monkeys whatever
let me let me explain as a master tick
talker now
you're a master tech you you've been
posting tick tocks no but i've been
messing around with it we had some
workout videos on there
messing around with it and if you use
the actual commercial music they have
limits between
15 seconds 30 seconds 60 seconds and so
those actually mess with your edits
oh you have to edit to that length yep
but if you use the royalty free one
you just use the whole thing so it was
probably messy that's if you're doing it
in ab
but i bet if you if you hit that sound
in that app on this video it's probably
been used by
so many people who do that kind of style
of their storytelling
yeah exactly you know what's funny is
that my comedic mind
immediately started going if this story
was just a little bit different where
she didn't like him back
it would be a psycho story well the
thing is
right i mean if he kept going that'd be
funny so this is what happened first so
they had met on tick tock right yeah
she started following him and then
uh they ended up like he said in the
story like he slid into her dms they
started talking and then eventually he
moved on to like face timing all the
time
and then so they were talking for a
really long time and then
before going on this road trip she said
that he had to stay
with her and her sister in la for a few
days so the sister could scope him out
and
see if she wow before heading out
and so like there was a lot of vetting
wait was was she even there
she was like staying with her sister she
goes let me [ __ ] him first sister
and i'll make sure he's okay that's a
good call
that's so funny yeah cause it's it's
kind of crazy
like just straight up online like that
because
sometimes i'm like okay i date online
too but i'm like
how do you know you can trust me you're
so trusting
that's love though right like that's
just love like it's always high risk
exactly like even if you met them like
at the library or at a restaurant or at
the club or a bar whatever
you're still taking the chance but i'll
be like
you're so nice and then my the second
part of me
immediately goes like but that's not
safe well we think that too
we think that too we're like [ __ ] i
can't believe we're here well we hope we
don't die
yeah i mean that's why a lot of times
when people meet up after like an online
dating thing
a lot of times i'll have like their
friends secretly hang out nearby too
just in case
the newspaper and the cut out eyes i've
seen this guy turn the page
because you get bored the same comic
yeah because you get bored
yeah i mean we do that like when we play
at colleges and stuff and we have the
organization pick us up
they could easily there's a leap of
faith there but faith man
i always think the other way i don't
think like they could kill me
i'm thinking like you could kill you
have the opportunity i'm like why do you
trust me like i could kill you right now
like why are you so trusting like isn't
that dangerous for you
it makes more sense because you're a
public person so that's true
you have a lot more to lose than a
completely like stranger like
i thought i felt like that when uber
first started too yeah me too
i could fart in your car right now i'm
standing i'm sitting behind you like i
could stab you right now
i can i don't why wouldn't you want me
to only sit in the front seat
so i'm like damn these guys these uber
drivers are really trusting the people
yeah still even now
it's not the opposite i'm like [ __ ] i'm
i'm getting in this car
he could easily just drive anywhere he
wants and then [ __ ] rape me and kill
me
yeah but then guys can't turn like this
you know like that's why girls can reach
things behind them but guys they get
stuck we're not flexible yeah
oh yeah it's okay oh and that's that's
so sit right behind them that's what i'm
gonna
say because you'll be like [ __ ] i'm
trying to rape you but i can't
yeah i mean at least like with taxis
they have the [ __ ] wall true
that's why uber i don't i don't i'm i'm
still surprised it's still functioning
hey some people take the risk if they
need the monies you know
yeah and then in this case like she
risked it for love she yeah so they're
they just they're together we don't know
herself now they're together
no she was she says i want to i want to
see a cute tick tock thing on her side
that's the one there we got this guy and
i liked his uh instagram
but before that i actually saw him two
years ago and i kept watching him and
following him
so i moved closer actually so close i'm
in the next apartment right
adjacent to his window and i see him
every night and then i realized
i might be too close we're getting too
close maybe i should go really far and
then he can ask me out on a road trip
that would be funny well i got with my
family and i said hey sis
can i just hang out in la with you and
like we all kind of get together and get
to know this guy
and she was like cool i'm game yeah
that's the story
i do like how acceptable it is you know
that someone could fall in love like on
an app that's not necessarily meant for
dating like
i mean instagram i'm sure is a better
dating app have you dated online before
yeah there was like a period in between
my last this is my thing i wish
online had is i wish you could smell
them
because sometimes it'll be amazing right
you guys be cool and you're like oh i
love your thoughts you are so
cool and then you meet them and you go
you smell you smell man you smell so
so wait wait do you smell good so that
you can even say that
no i don't know if i smell good i
probably smell horrible oh okay uh
sometimes people don't smell bad i don't
like them
you know humans have their own
fingerprint
okay a smelly print you know like they
have their own little aura
and some people you're like oh man what
are you a turtle like it's just weird
it's turtle you know like you're just
pretty stinky just yes
you were animals like what your slider
like what the [ __ ]
something that type of turtle yeah
that's a good point joe
yeah you know what i'm talking about
right i like that some people
you can wash your clothes in the laundry
and pull it out and you're like
oh i could [ __ ] i could sleep in your
smell
oh it smells so good right but some
people you're like smelling it and
you're like
okay this is clean but it's not clean
wash it again why why
but women don't smell as bad as guys but
they do though some people just
they just smell really yeah yeah that's
what the first date is for
to smell them i just physically just
singing
yeah but what if you committed in this
case like all the all that time
talking that's true yeah that was a
person road trip
he smelled in la that's what happened
and then that's when you
send he sent this sweatshirt he did send
him all right
that's how you smell the details pick up
investigate the sweater though
make that new dating app you know
somewhere in the middle you have to send
each other something
they love some war i like that idea it's
still like the smell out of the way
yeah it smells important send a condom i
used hormones like the pheromones yes
yeah because sometimes i mean like girls
be dank too like after
life [ __ ] happens you know i you know
people get dank
but it doesn't it doesn't bother me like
like there are pis
i get stinks but it's temporary right
but like it's because of the amount of
hair too the hair makes it worse
their smells become more acceptable i'll
[ __ ] lick that [ __ ] dirty
[Music]
haha
[Music]
you